ladies and gentlemen
the president of the united states and
the first lady
dr jill
[Applause]
on biden i know i know
good to see you man how are you
it's great nice to see how you doing i
feel silly sitting down for a while
i'm joe biden i'm jill's husband
before i sign let me uh start with a few
words uh
about what's going on now in in florida
and uh you know the people
who are here who are part of what
happened that night
at the pulse nightclub and the
scores that i just spoke to a moment ago
they're online
looking at this they understand that
what it's like to have to wait and
wonder what happened
the families i remember going down there
to the pulse nightclub afterwards and
and uh wondering is it my
son my daughter my husband someone i
love
that who got lost because he didn't know
for certain initially
and as uh as congressman cecilia knows
there's nothing worse than having to
wait
and wonder what happened and uh
i know val when you were a police chief
you had to go through waiting a lot as
well
and uh and so i just want to say i've
spoken to governor desantis
and uh we provided all the help that
they have they need we sent the best
people from fema down there
we're going to stay with them with the
disaster declaration we made
provide for everything from housing to
god forbid
whether there's a need for moratoria
for for the bodies to be placed
everything in between
and but i just i just want to say and
i'm sure i speak for
all the members of the congress here
today and and all the survivors here
that
uh that it's a tough tough time
there's so many people waiting are they
alive will they be
will it happen and so our heart goes out
to them and
uh i the people of florida i wanna
i've spoken to debbie wasserman schultz
i've spoken to
most of the folks down there and a
member in authority
and i promise you the administration the
congress are doing everything
possible to be of assistance now and
after
this occurs after they decide
exactly what the state of play is but
i'm glad to welcome everyone here
to the adjuncts to the white house here
and
in person and virtually survivors and
family members victims and uh the
path-breaking leaders like uh senator
baldwin just over five years ago the
pulse nightclub
a place of acceptance and joy became a
place of unspeakable pain
and loss and we'll never fully recover
but we'll remember and we have to
what we're going to do is what the
members of congress here did
enshrine in law as a consequence
of that law enshrined in perpetuity
literally monument to the loss that
occurred there and an
absolute determination that we're going
to deal with this
every single solitary day and
make sure that we're not in a position
to see this happen again behind me
you see on either board there the 49
lives lost
family members parents friends veterans
students
young black asian latino all fellow
americans
and in their memory and for the
countless others forever scarred
is why i sign this today and let me say
how much i appreciate i mean this
sincerely the
the the commitment of the members of the
house and senate
to make sure that we don't forget
that this isn't for god now there's a
tradition
when a bill is signed that the president
gives a signing pin to each of the
people who had something to do with
the law or the decision being made in
the first place
i promise you i have all the pens put in
the other room i couldn't figure out how
to
sign them but don't leave without the
pen okay
all right all right
maybe we never have to sign and i've no
president never have to sign another
monument like this
one last thing as i said to uh
to the survivors and those who lost
folks
a little earlier in private
you know what the congress has done
means a great deal
and it's important but it's really hard
it brings back everything as if it
happened yesterday
and every time there's a memorial
service for our son
you know you're you're flattered you
feel good about it you think it's
it's wonderful the recognition but it's
uh it's tough
because it's as if it happened yesterday
it happened the day before it happened
the moment you
signed it so i want to thank the folks
who are here and the folks
who are survivors are on on zoom with us
i want to thank them for their courage i
really mean it
for their courage but i promise you none
of the members of congress that are here
and our eye and our jill are going to
let up until we deal with equity across
the board
thank you so very much
you got to come back and get your pens
all right i'll end up with 17 pens that
i don't know what to do